that doesn't make any sense to me so let
me challenge you on that okay so you
said that that ice age happened when and
and it lasted for 150 how many years
100 million 100 million years and it was
uh it was called a keru
k-r-k-a-r-double o how long ago was that
it began 350 million years ago and ended
250 million years ago and it's in
wikipedia and everywhere else no no i'm
not questioning that that that didn't
exist but what doesn't make any sense is
what then when that did happen
how many people were living on the
planet 350 million years ago modern life
was well established at that time for
forests were established
animals were established insects were
established all the sea life was already
established how about human like how
about us it doesn't matter we're a
mammal but wait a minute i'm asking you
a question it doesn't matter no it's
context no let me tell you why it
doesn't because yourself myself and all
of us in this room yeah and everybody in
this world and all the animals and
plants all came from then no that's not
what i'm asking no no you wouldn't be
here if if it wasn't of course listen
you're on a podcast so you're going to
get a challenge if you're uncomfortable
with it i'm going to keep challenging
you so you can challenge me i'm
comfortable with this i'm ready so so
going back to it so as do you think if i
talk on my phone for 12 hours straight
every day for two years you think that
radiation's gonna hurt me a little bit
no you don't think it's gonna hurt me at
all no okay do you think the whole thing
with radiations being near
uh plants nuclear plants or you know the
the wiring you know how uh uh
5g you're talking about not five gallons
i'm not going conspiracy i'm just going
straight up like if you live close to
plants that have a lot of uh
radiation you think that's bad for you
and i no at all zero okay no because
they don't have a lot of radiation
they're shielded and they have less
radiation than standing near a granite
wall in many cases granite has radiation
do you think a guy who works near
choppers and planes
there are side effects that's going to
hurt his hearing over a time of 10 20
years only if he gets hit by the
propeller
there's gonna be
hearing i was in the army myself and
they would say wear these things because
if you okay but sometimes eventually
there's some side effects to it right
okay
there's no way i can compare
how peaceful a building was
with nobody working and living in it
versus how peaceful a building is with
200 people living in that building
there's going to be more things breaking
with 200 people living in a building
than when that building was built up and
nobody's living in it there's going to
be things that's going to happen there's
going to be deterioration because we're
going to naturally do that when i bought
my house my house was
brand spanking new clean white walls all
this stuff come take a look at some of
the white walls see what my four kids
have done okay the other i'm like jim
what is this all about baby i don't even
know how they broke that okay we got to
get a fix right okay
so i'm not sitting here saying it's your
climate change is real but i'm saying if
i'm gonna match data to data
you can't say data to data and there's
no human you know mankind living here
versus there's mankind living today i
don't know i'm this is not my world i'm
not a doctor i'm not a scientist i'm not
a phd i'm a person that questions things
to wonder there has to be some kind of
correlation here with what we're doing
to hurt this if we are in any possible
way so when you say that and say ice age
all this stuff i'm not quite cool but we
were not around
so we came around things have changed
ever since man kind of started producing
things you could look at dubai what
dubai looked like 40 years ago you ever
seen a picture what dubai looks like
today it ain't the same place
to completely different place so we have
some kind of an impact on it my question
becomes is the following
um what's the capacity in this building
how many people hundred people 150
people but how about if we really are
super cheap and we want to max this
place out 200 people 200 people can we
have 500 people working in this building
hell no is it no or hell no
it is hell no it is hell no i agree with
you
there we have a nice building just for
the record it's not what i'm saying that
has nothing to do with nice build we
have a nice uh you know planet that
we're living in
what's our capacity and what kind of a
negative impact are we making into it if
any that's my curiosity yeah cities
occupy about 2.5 of the land
on the earth and the land is only 25
percent of the earth the other 75 is the
ocean where very few people are living
so we have actually the people who live
in the cities yeah think the whole world
is a city i think i think they never go
outside to see what's out there or fly
over it to see what's underneath how
many farms and forests there are across
the united states of america i've flown
over every country in the world
practically let me give you one example
europe the whole of europe like the eu
200 years ago was down to less than 10
percent forest
they had
been using wood
but this is before fossil fuels were
used extensively so they were using wood
for all their energy for heating all
their buildings for making steel and
copper and glass
and steam engines so they had started to
deplete the forests and the forests
weren't growing back naturally as fast
as they were being cut for industry and
heating
and so silviculture was born the science
of growing forests and whereas
agriculture started about 10 000 years
ago growing food it was not necessary
to learn how to grow trees because there
were so many of them and so few people
that up until then no one had learned
how to farm trees so silviculture began
in central europe
in the eastern part
and today europe has 43 percent forest
cover
more than four times nearly five times
what it had two hundred years ago and
that is the result of humans
farming trees
and the trees are native trees
in some countries they farm trees that
come from other countries they call them
exotic trees like in south america for
example there are really no native trees
that are good for forestry because they
grow too slowly new zealand is the same
a lot of the southern hemisphere has
forests that grow very slowly but they
can import pines from california in new
zealand and monterey pine and develop a
huge forest industry and exporting wood
to japan and china by the score and at
the same time creating a forest where
there wasn't one before because it had
been turned into a grassland with sheep
on it and that's why new zealand has so
many sheep because it wasn't worth
growing trees back on the land after you
fell the trees for wood so they brought
in sheep
now they're putting those same pastures
back to forest in many cases china and
india have produced more new forest
cover in the last 50 years than all the
rest of the world put together
and in fact china and india are between
the two of them emitting more than 50
percent of all the carbon dioxide
in the world today
therefore they are contributing to the
most to the fertilization of the air
with co2 to grow more food crops and
forests that's why there's record
harvests every year about 70 percent of
the increase in our food crops are
are because of additional carbon dioxide
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]